[Musique]
on sera toutes et à tous
si je suis ici ce soir c'est parce que
je suis une héroïne alors pas une super
héroïne c'est à dire que lorsque
j'appuie ici et aucune toile d'araignée
qui sort je sais absolument pas grimper
aux murs et encore moins sauter de toit
en toit parce que j'ai le vertige
je ne suis pas non plus une héroïne au
sens médiatique du terme
mise à part les insectes qui se noie
régulièrement dans la gamelle d'eau de
ma chienne j'ai jamais sauvé personne de
la noyade
en fait je suis juste juste l'héroïne de
moi même
l'héroïne de ma vie et ça met en joie
parce que ça remplit ma vie de sens au
quotidien mais j'ai pas toujours été
héroïne de ma vie avant j'étais actrice
je jouais mon propre rôle et je le
jouais plutôt bien alors je suis pas
venu devenue héroïne du jour au
lendemain
j'étais même particulièrement lente il
m'a fallu plus de sept ans et je me suis
pas non plus lever un matin comme ça en
me disant tiens flou si tu devenais
l'héroïne de ta vie non il m'a fallu un
déclic une prise de conscience un petit
caillou dans l'engrenage de ma vie
quotidienne
mon challenge ce soir c'est faire en
sorte que chacun et chacune d'entre vous
devienne ce soir commence à devenir le
héros ou l'héroïne de leur vie j'espère
qu'avec mon histoire je vais de ce petit
caillou dans votre andreu nages enfin
dans l'engrenage de certains parce que
parmi vous
certaines et certains sont déjà
l'héroïne le héros de leur vie et
peut-être même de plus en plus parce que
je crois fort au fait que dans les
jeunes générations vous êtes de plus en
plus connecté à votre mot intérieur moi
j'ai 37 ans n'a pas forcément été le cas
donc je vais faire appel ce soir au
héros et or in parmi vous je vous
demandais de m'accompagner de votre
énergie bienveillante
tout au long de cette histoire que je
vais vous raconter
et puis pour les autres eh bien j'espère
que je vais être le petit caillou et la
petite bougie pour donner aussi envie à
ceux qui ont déjà commencé leur parcours
et qui semble que des fois c'est
difficile qui se disent c'est long et
quand est-ce que je vais y arriver est
bien de leur donner l'espoir et de leur
dire continuer persévérer
il ya un trésor au bout du voyage alors
eh bien si vous êtes prête est prêt
commençons le voyage du héros et de
l'héroïne il était une fois vous dans
votre vie une vie croissante et linéaire
vous avez vos croyances
vous avez vos certitudes vous avez vos
valeurs vos réflexes d habitude
et puis dans cette ville in her et
croissante par moments il ya quand même
quelques petites turbulences des petites
questions que vous vous posez
est ce que ma vie ferait vraiment sens
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas certaines choses
mais bon être humain a horreur du
changement pourquoi changer
quand tout va à peu près bien alors vous
continuez vous continuez jusqu'à ce
qu'un jour sans que ça préviennent votre
avion tombe tout s'effondre
dans votre vie vos croyances vos valeurs
tout tombe dans l'océan et vous vous
retrouvez au milieu des débris a essayé
de nager et à survivre
c'est exactement ça que j'ai ressenti le
jour où alors que j'étais enceinte de
six mois de grossesse
le spécialiste en génétique qui nous
recevait mon mari et moi même nous a
expliqué échographie et preuve
scientifique à l'appui que la petite
fille que je portais était atteinte
d'une maladie tellement grave que la
seule bonne solution était ce qu'on
appelle une interruption médicale de
grossesse
je me souviens de ce moment précis en
fait vous avez conscience qui a eu un
avant dans votre vie et vous n'êtes pas
conscience qu'il y aura un après par
contre vous rendez compte que ça sera
jamais plus comme avant
et cette rupture ce petit caillou qui
s'est mis dans votre engrenage ils
arrivent sans prévenir ces soudains et
vous le subissent et intégralement parce
que vous l'avez pas du tout anticipé
alors vous retrouvez dans votre séant à
nager à nager à essayer de survivre à
l'instant de survie crème
quand tout à coup une bouée venu de
nulle part qui tombe comme ça devant
vous alors c'est vous et vous dites j'ai
peut-être intérêt à la saisir parce
qu'il n'aura peut-être pas une deuxième
alors vous accrocher fermement et c'est
debout et vous amène au rivage d'une île
déserte une terre inconnue
là vous avez plus aucun repère vous
connaissez rien sur cette île déserte
alors vous faites confiance à votre
instinct et puis aussi aux 2 3 épisodes
de koh lanta vous avez à votre actif
quand même et donc vous arrivez à vous
nourrir à vous vêtir à construire une
cabane pour vous abriter
et puis au fil des jours ça commence à
bien vous plaire finalement cette vie
vous ressentez quelque chose de tout
nouveau c'est la liberté
plus besoin de jouer de rôle et puis
personne de toute façon vous vous avez
juste être vous même en fait et à vivre
au temps présent à vivre à faire les
choses et ça vous fait du bien ça vous
met en joie
moi mon île déserte ça a été une
formation maquillage artistique qui m'a
permis de pendant mon congé maternité
son bébé est bien de renouer avec la
petite fille que j'avais été qui était
passionné de dessin et peinture et donc
je donnais vie et forme sur les visages
à l'aide d'épongé de pinceau je me suis
vraiment reconnecter à mon enfant
intérieur et à ma créativité
bon et puis vous restez pas indéfiniment
sur votre île déserte on finit par vous
géolocaliser l'époque de robinson crusoé
et on vous rapatrier dans votre ancien
monde il n'ya plus votre avion ya plus
votre vie vraiment à vous mais l'ancien
monde existe encore au début vous êtes
content parce que vous dites
celle là je la maîtrise quand même de
vie je connais je connaissais principe
je connais comment ça fonctionne alors
eh ben vous vous dites que ça va
peut-être commencer comme avant sauf
qu'il n'ya plus rien qui fonctionne
comme avant les personnes qui vous amuse
et qui vous intéressait commence à vous
ennuyer pas tout un certaine les
activités qui vous plaisait vous ennuie
alors vous commencez à regretter cet
ancien monde que vous avez connu juste
avant cette île déserte vous étiez vous
même vous commenciez vraiment je sais
pas à trouver quelque chose en connexion
avec vous même moi c'est ce qui m'est
vraiment arrivé c'est à dire que du jour
au lendemain j'ai claqué la porte à mon
identité de cadres dans les ressources
humaines
patiemment façonné année après année et
justes donc passé de cadres rh à
maquilleuse de rue
un grand écart et quand j'ai fait cette
décision quand j'ai pris cette décision
non pas que je n'aimais plus les
ressources humaines donc pas que je
n'avais pas aimé mon métier mais en fait
j'ai su que je ne pourrai plus jamais
redevenir celle que j'avais été je
pouvais seulement devenir celle qui
allait clore petit à petit alors comme
cet ancien monde on parle plus eh bien
vous décider à les construire votre
propre demande
et là on arrive au coeur de l'intrigué
au coeur du voyage du héros et de
l'héroïne ça dure plusieurs années
en tout cas pour moi ç'a duré plusieurs
années vous savez c'est le moment où il
ya les pièges les monstres et dragons
il ya des épreuves a dépassé terrain et
donc vous tombez une fois deux fois
trois fois
moi j'ai dû tomber même dix fois je
crois sur certaines choses j'étais
particulièrement lente à comprendre
et puis vous commencez à développer de
nouveaux réflexes vous aborder la vie
d'une nouvelle manière et il ya
plusieurs leçons vous pourriez retenir
deux de toute cette étape du voyage
j'en ai retenu trois pour vous ce soir
vous apprenez à suivre votre coeur vous
savez petit truc qui bat vous avez là
votre coeur c'est celui qui dit je veux
j'aime j'ai envie je vibre c'est ce qui
est spontané c'est ce qui fait sens
immédiatement au contraire du mental qui
va être plutôt dans le jeu doit il faut
et qui va se restreindre le coeur
s'ouvre le mental a tendance à nous
renfermer
et puis vous suivez aussi votre
intuition
alors contrairement à ce qu'on croit
l'intuition c'est pas réservé qu'aux
femmes
tout le monde a de l'intuition vous
savez c'est cette petite fulgurances qui
passe comme ça et puis qui fait que vous
savez qu'il faut y aller et si vous la
suivez cette intuition
elle va vous jamais vous emmener vers un
danger et va au contraire vous amener
sur votre chemin
par contre elle pourra vous faire sortir
de votre zone de confort ça c'est sûr
l'intuition c'est celle qui peut entrer
des fois en opposition avec notre raison
la raison celle qui nous dire ce que je
devrais je devrais pas en pèse le pour
et le contre
c'est pas instantanée essayez-vous et
celle là par contre elle vous fait vous
connecter à vos peurs troisième élément
que vous apprenez au cours de cette
longue étape la cclat vie effectivement
le temps peut être linéaire et vous
rendez compte aussi que finalement votre
vie et cycliques
regardez dans la nature printemps été
automne hiver
vous n'échapperez pas à cette règle
vous n'échapperez pas à cette règle dans
le sens où vous mourrez et rené s'est
régulièrement à vous même vous êtes en
évolution permanente en transformation
permanente et le fait de voir votre vie
de manière cyclique
eh bien vous amène a lâché derrière vous
ce qui n'est plus vous régulièrement
telle une mue comme un serpent et puis
vous avez pris l'habitude que cette
étape finalement du voyage dure
longtemps et vous n'attendez même plus
vous souvenez même plus qui est un
trésor bien beau jour il arrive ce
trésor est ce trésor il arrive en fait
au moment où vous ne vous y attendez pas
ou ne vous y attendez plus ce trésor il
arrive au moment où vous avez lâché
prise au moment où vous ne cherchez plus
ce qui vous manquait pour être comme les
autres moments vous avez trouvé ce que
vous aviez de différents et pour être
vous même en fait après les débuts de
mon entreprise dans le maquillage
artistique
j'ai évolué vers l'esthétique conseil en
image et puis des outils de
développement personnel avec
l'ennéagramme et puis voilà jeté une
sorte d'hybride comme ça je faisais du
maquillage sont sans me sentir
maquilleuse l'esthétique sans me sentir
esthéticienne alors j'avais mon c ap et
j'avais du mal à dire qui jetait et là
avec ce trésor tout d'un coup qui arrive
eh bien j'ai réussi à dire qui jetait à
rayonner qui j'étais et les autres
comprenez qui jetait alors ce trésor
c'est quoi ce trésor s'est rarement une
princesse ou un prince épouse est
rarement un sac d'or que ce trésor en
fait il est étroitement liée à votre
problématique personnelle à votre
blessure fondamentale
à celle qui fait que vous êtes lancés
dans cette aventure de héros et
d'héroïne pour ma part ces trésors c est
l arrivée de ma fille margot au bout de
ma quatrième grossesse
le problème génétique qu'on avait cru
être un accident la première fois c'est
en fait perpétré encore deux autres fois
et donc j'attendais plus finalement
d'enfants j'étais dans l'acceptation
totale de me dire voilà on lâche prise
et puis on avance et ma fille est
arrivée et avec ma fille de la confiance
ne l'estiment de moi qui m'a permis non
seulement de développer ma confiance et
mon assurance au niveau personnel mais
aussi professionnel aujourd'hui
j'accompagne les femmes à devenir
l'héroïne de leur vie et je le fais
comme personne d'autre
parce que je suis personne d'autre alors
on arrive au terme de ce voyage qui je
l'espère aura provoqué être un déclic
prise de conscience pour certains je
remercie aussi tous les héros et
héroïnes parmi vous qui m'ont envoyé
leurs bonnes ondes
et puis pour terminer j'aimerais
m'adresser à celles et à ceux qui sont
encore dans leur avion et qui n'ont pas
encore l'intention de le quitter
vous je vous comprends parce que moi
c'est pas un petit caillou une histoire
de 15 minutes qu'il a fallu pour que je
quitte mon avion avant qu'il ne s'écrase
c'était un gros rocher quand même alors
vous j'aimerais vous dire je comprends
votre peur je comprends vos réticences
faut avoir peur de perdre ce qu'on
connaît ce qu'on maîtrise et ceux qu'on
aime
mais on perd jamais l'essentiel vous
savez la personne qui est dans ma vie
aujourd'hui c'est toujours la personne
c'est la même personne qu au début de
mon voyage et je la remercie d'ailleurs
alors pour ceux qui doutent encore
qu'ils ne se sentent pas prêts je vous
donne un petit exercice à faire
vous allez construire un petit avion en
papier si vous ne savez pas les faire
c'était mon cas je vous donnerai numéro
de ma maman elle est ok c'est donc
construire ce petit avion en papier et
le poser sur votre table de nuit
chaque soir quand vous rentrerez
mentalement avec votre coeur vous y
mettrez tous que dans la journée vous
avez fait et qui était pas vous tous les
rêves que vous avez nourri qui n'étaient
pas les vôtres
tous les projets que vous êtes poursuivi
qui était pas non plus les vôtres et
tout ça soir après soir et encore et
encore et encore jusqu'au soir où vous
travaillez vous semblera vraiment lourd
et poussiéreux de tout ce que vous
n'êtes pas ou de tout ce que vous n'êtes
plus et ce soir-là de vous-même vous
laisserai tomber cet avion sans dommage
puisque ce soir là vous serez prêt à
devenir le héros ou l'héroïne de votre
vie pour de bon vous serez prêt à faire
ce premier pas qui est le plus difficile
mais qui en vaut la peine
merci
[Applaudissements]